das treffen in der türkei heute hat
wenig bis nichts gebracht in der ukraine
fallen weiter bomben hat diplomatie im
moment überhaupt eine chance und was ist
die alternative mehr waffen und
flugzeuge schicken
flugverbotszonen härtere sanktionen mehr
flüchtlinge aufnehmen was sollte
deutschland tun und wozu ist es bereit
wir müssen reden mit diesen gästen
daniel andrä kommandeur der nato einsatz
truppe in litauen
der spd vorsitzende lars klingbeil
friedrich merz cdu vorsitzender und
fraktionschef
die berliner sozialsenatorin katja
kipping
der militärexperte carlo masala
katja gloger journalistin und russland
expertin
und der spd politiker klaus von dohnanyi
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner
und ich begrüße die gäste ausgesprochen
herzlich heute und anfangen wollen wir
mit unserem gast in hamburg klaus von
dohnanyi einen guten abend zu ihnen ich
darf verraten dass sie im sommer dieses
jahres 94 jahre als werden als einziger
aus der runde hier heute abend haben sie
den zweiten weltkrieg noch miterlebt im
sogenannten volkssturm als 16-jähriger
und nun gibt es wieder einen krieg in
europa
2022 wie viel schrecken füllen sie
also das ganze ist für mich so
erschreckend besonders wenn ich dann aus
der ukraine die sirenen heulen höhere
und michael wie das war wenn die bombe
über uns flogen und wir die sirenen in
berlin oder wo auch immer werden also es
ist schrecklich und es ist ein großes
verbrechen von putin gewesen diesen
krieg so zu beginn nie wieder krieg war
einer der leitsätze vor allem der
deutschen sozialdemokratie nicht nur ihr
aber vor allem dieser partei warum ist
es gescheitert wenn sie versuchen würden
darauf eine antwort zu finden
also wir haben ja alles versucht und ich
glaube die sozialdemokratie hat auch in
der vergangenheit besonders natürlich in
den zeiten in denen wir in der
vergangenheit auch regiert haben also in
zeiten willy brandt und in zeiten helmut
schmidt haben wir natürlich immer
versucht kompromisse zu finden und ohne
kompromisse kann man auch keine
vernünftige politik machen und was mir
in den vergangenen jahren ein wenig
gefehlt hat ist dass wir vielleicht im
westen zu manchen kompromissen nicht
bereit genug waren andererseits haben
wir natürlich auch putin falsch
eingeschätzt wir werden darüber heute
abend diskutieren beginnen mit einem
blick auf die aktuelle lage treffen
finden statt telefonate unablässig so
auch an diesem heutigen tag und an der
situation ändert sich dennoch wenig
der türkische aussenminister empfängt
seine russischen und ukrainischen
amtskollegen das erste treffen seit
kriegsbeginn die gedämpften erwartungen
werden noch unterboten keinerlei
fortschritt nur das bekenntnis zu
weiteren gesprächen
ich bin bereit mich wieder in diesem
format zu treffen wenn es aussicht auf
lösungen gibt
präsident putin hat nichts gegen ein
treffen mit präsident selenz geld
am ende wird man also wieder mit ihm
reden müssen auf augenhöhe an einem
tisch westliche regierungschefs statt
russischer flugbegleiterinnen
unsere armee kämpft für die
entnazifizierung und die
entmilitarisierung der ukraine dafür
dass kein anti russland entsteht das
seit jahren an unserer grenze aufgebaut
wird
reden gegen den krieg
täglich turbo diplomatie
doch jeder tag krieg treibt den preis
des friedens höher
für putin
für selensky
für den westen
carlo masala ist bei uns von der
bundeswehr universität in münchen
hermann seiler herausgekommen ist nun
heute wieder nicht viel kann ein solches
treffen ein solches erstes treffen der
beiden außenminister dennoch einen sinn
machen ja es macht absolut sinn weil es
durchaus der beginn einer reihe von
gesprächen sein kann an dem an dessen
ende vielleicht eine annäherung steht
das wort man heute kein ergebnis hat war
zu erwarten angesichts der forderungen
die auch putin gestellt hat für eine
waffenruhe und sozusagen einen frieden
in der ukraine aber dass man redet dass
man bereit ist weiter zu reden ist schon
mal ein positives zeichen jetzt muss man
aber einschränkend sagen wir kennen das
auch oft von putin dass er diese
diplomatischen verhandlungen benutzt um
mehr zeit zu gewinnen auf dem boden also
in der ukraine um dort sozusagen
militärisch vorzugehen nach auch
superwurf der franzosen die haben gesagt
der nutzt jetzt diese zeit nur um im
grunde auch das reden um waffenruhe und
korridore nutzt ihm nur um
vorbereitungen zu treffen für neue
bombardements also wir sehen seit 23
tagen dass die russen sich in der
ukraine am re gruppieren sind und es
kann natürlich sein dass er mehr zeit
braucht um auch die truppen logistisch
zu versorgen um diese gruppierung
abzuschließen das kann man nicht
ausschließen also von daher es kann
beides möglich sein es kann der anfang
von gesprächen sein es kann aber auch
sozusagen nur eine taktik sein um mehr
zeit zu schinden und ich glaube man hat
ja auch gesehen bei den verhandlungen
die makro und die olaf scholz mit putin
geführt haben ja alle richtig waren aber
aller wahrscheinlichkeit nach war für
putin seit dezember klar dass er nur
zeit braucht um die truppen so zu
massieren um dann in die ukraine allein
zu fallen und er hat diese ganzen
diplomatischen sache nur genutzt um zeit
zu schinden also von daher man sollte
vorsichtig sein nicht zu euphorisch aber
zur kenntnis nehmen dass jetzt
zumindestens mal ein diplomatischer weg
offen ist kann eine evakuierung von kiew
beispielsweise gelingen ohne dass es
vorher eine waffenruhe gibt
also ich bin sehr skeptisch aber mit
diesen humanitären korridoren weil ich
finde den begriff schon zynisch genug
weil wir wissen von den russen dass sie
sozusagen damit die zivilbevölkerung
auffordern rauszugehen ab einem gewissen
zeitpunkt gibt es diesen korridor nicht
mehr und wer nicht rausgehen kann oder
will wird von den russen zu kombattanten
erklärt und damit zu legitimen ziele und
dann fangen sie diese städte an dem
erdboden gleich zu machen also grosny da
sind wir noch nicht so aber das ist
eigentlich russische strategie von daher
sozusagen man kann evakuieren ohne dass
es eine waffenruhe gibt es können
partielle waffenruhen sein aber ich
erwarte das auch während der
verhandlungen weiter gekämpft wird weil
es ist essenziell wenn man nach es geht
um territoriale tät wenn man nachher
irgendwie zu einer übereinkunft kommen
sollte dann bitte ich natürlich auf der
basis dessen was die kampf parteien
erreicht haben an territorium gewonnen
haben geführt und deshalb ist es
illusorisch zu glauben dass jetzt die
waffen schweigen werden und die stunde
der diplomatie ist dergestalt dass die
kampfhandlungen eingestellt werden katja
gloger ist bei uns gesetze journalisten
kollegin hat lange in moskau gelebt in
den usa eine dicke sehr kluge putin
biografie geschrieben mit dem titel
putins welt konnte man präsident
seelands g zuletzt so verstehen die krim
und dem don was könnt ihr haben wenn ihr
uns in frieden lässt
so konnte man ihn nicht verstehen die
krippen und den don was könnt ihr haben
wenn ihr uns in frieden dass das hat er
ja ausdrücklich und wir ausgeschlossen
scania in dieser situation auch auch gar
nicht anbieten
sein gedanke einer möglichen
ukrainischen neutralität
der könnte auf lange sicht aber nicht
jetzt aber auf lange sicht könnte eine
möglichkeit sein in ernstere
verhandlungen zu treten
eine neutralität die allerdings
sicherheitsgarantien
erfordern würde nicht nur ein
sicherheitsversprechen wie wir es im
budapester memorium von 1994 erlebt
haben genau sondern feste garantien und
diese garantie sollte dann auch russland
geben und es gibt im moment keinerlei
anzeichen dafür dass russland also
sprich präsident putin dazu bereit ist
ganz im gegenteil das klingt ist bei uns
der spd-vorsitzende erklingen bei womit
fangen wir an mit gerhard schröder macht
heute schlagzeilen er ist auf einem
geheimbesuch in moskau offensichtlich
wird sich putin ausgerechnet von
jemandem überzeugen lassen der
eigentlich sein angestellter ist
bin selbst gespannt also ich war auch
überrascht sage ich ganz offen hat sich
heute mitbekommen habe dass gerd
schröder dort unterwegs ist jetzt wieder
im auftrag der spd noch im auftrag der
bundesregierung unterwegs ich wusste
davon nichts die regierungsvertreter mit
denen ich geredet habe wussten davon
auch nichts also dass mir auch sehr klar
gesagt worden das wusste niemand
ich sag mal so alles was hilft gerade um
diesen furchtbaren krieg zu beenden ist
ja willkommen aber ob das jetzt gelingt
das werden wir dann vielleicht in den
nächsten stunden in den nächsten tagen
sehen ich finde auf jeden fall dass
gesprächssituation die gerade geschaffen
werden und die stadt finden hier erstmal
etwas vernünftiges auf ihren brief hat
gerhard schröder aber noch nicht
geantwortet ist unterwegs also unterwegs
er kann nicht an worten treffen der
außenminister heute hat es relativ wenig
gebracht was denken sie will wladimir
putin tatsächlich lieber eine kaputte
ukraine als eine neutrale ukraine ich
finde das schwierig da zu spekulieren
ich bin noch kein militär x-pert ich
sehen der tat auch und das ist die
bewertung die ich jetzt seit tagen
bekomme das wohl alles nicht so läuft
wie wladimir putin sich das vorgestellt
hatte wie anscheinend ja ein enger
berater kreis ein immer enger gewordene
beraterkreis ihm das auch gesagt hat und
prognostiziert hat das ist erstmal ein
positives zeichen dass er nicht zuvor an
kommt aber ich kann nicht in den kopf
dieser person gucken so wird klaus von
dohnanyi das gerade gesagt putin hat uns
belogen er hat uns sagen auch sagen ein
gespräche geführt ohne dass er den
willen hatte diese gespräche ernsthaft
zu ende zu führen oder auch
diplomatische lösung zu finden insofern
ist es schwierig aber das was wir immer
wieder sagen müssen und was ich auch von
putin erwarte ist dass es jetzt zu einem
waffenstillstand kommt dass dieses töten
dort beendet wird und ja dann wird man
gespräche führen können aber welchen
ausgang die haben das lässt sich heute
schwer voraussagen ich würde euch mehr
als cdu-vorsitzender und chef der cdu
csu fraktion herr merz kaum jemand
wünscht sich das aber wirkt der westen
am ende mit diesem wladimir putin
verhandeln müssen
das kann sich kaum jemand vorstellen
dass wir noch mal
diese situation kommen ich habe auf dem
weg hierher darüber nachgedacht ob wir
uns überhaupt vorstellen können mit
putin noch einmal an einem normalen
verhandlungstisch zu setzen dieser mann
ist mittlerweile ein schwerer
kriegsverbrecher und das ganze system
drum herum ebenfalls erlaubt auch und
deswegen habe ich große zweifel ob das
überhaupt noch mal zustande kommt wird
putin jemals wieder an einem
verhandlungsteam konferenztisch einer
staatengemeinschaft sitzen der mann wird
ein strafbefehl bekommen vom
internationalen strafgerichtshof
trotzdem muss man reden und muss alle
versuche unternehmen dieses diesem
konflikt irgendwie zu beenden allein mir
fehlt heute die fantasie kretschmann der
ministerpräsident von sachsen sagt
russland ist nicht serbien wir werden
diesen präsidenten nicht ohne weiteres
weg kriegen also er denkt dass wir uns
mit putin arrangieren müssen kann das am
ende so sein keiner weiß das von uns was
passiert und wenn man dieses zitat von
heute noch mal hört was sie gerade eben
auch eingespielt haben dass er von
wieder von der entnazifizierung der
ukraine spricht ein land das einen hohen
anteil jüdischer bevölkerung hat dann
muss ich sagen dass das ist so
beklemmend ich kann es mir nicht
vorstellen aber ich weiss niemand von
uns weiß wie dieser konflikt zu ende
geht von einem anti russland sprach er
auch klaus von dohnanyi frage zu ihnen
wer war es vielleicht ein fehler von
anfang an sie sprachen vorhin von
kompromissen die wir
hätten machen müssen sehen müssen war es
ein fehler der ukraine nicht von anfang
an zu sagen ihr werdet nicht in die nato
aufgenommen
war es ein fehler zu sagen und nicht
aufrichtig zu sagen
es wird notwendig sein dass ihr diesem
bündnis des westens eben nicht beitreten
also die härtesten vertreter der nato
expansion nach osten wache waren unter
anderem herr brezinski ein mann den hier
im kreise wahrscheinlich alle kennen ein
geo politiker ein sicherheitsberater in
den usa und ein gerhard
interessenvertreter der interessen der
usa in europa und er hat im mai
2015 vor sieben jahren ein interview in
der welt gegeben und hat in diesem
interview gesagt unter keinen umständen
dürfen wir die ukraine in die nato
nehmen das führt zu einem heißen krieg
das ist jetzt sieben jahre her und in
diesen sieben jahren hätte man natürlich
über diese frage in ruhe mit putin
verhandeln müssen und ich glaube das war
ein fehler auf der westlichen seite das
entschuldigt nichts von dem was putin
mit diesem krieg begonnen hat aber es
war ein fehler auf der westlichen seite
das nicht zu verstehen denn zu diesen
kritikern der nato expansion gehört ja
auch der heutige chef also der chef der
us geheimdienste herr burns
der hat in seinem buch
2009 10 veröffentlicht hatte beck
channel heißt das also der der canal
canal hinter der offiziellen linie in
diesem buch hat er ganz deutlich
geschrieben dass die nato expansion ein
fehler ist und dass sie auch nur eine
provokation für russland ist und ich
bedaure wirklich dass wir jetzt also da
widerspreche ich auch herrn merz in
vielen dingen stimme ich ihm zu aber ich
widerspreche doch an dem punkt natürlich
müssen wir mit putin verhandeln und
natürlich müssen wir mit putin
verhandeln indem wir versuchen jetzt zu
fragen ob es über den weg den sie
glänzen selber aufgemacht hat mit der
these wir brauchen vielleicht gar keine
mitgliedschaft in der nato sondern nur
ein anlehnen an europa genau das was
brosinski vorgeschlagen hat vielleicht
kann man damit heute weiterkommen er hat
masala wir gucken noch mal zurück putin
hat 2008 ihr spätestens zu verstehen
gegeben dass er die ukraine nie hergeben
würde er hat 2014 einen krieg geführt
und hat zu verstehen gegeben dass er die
ukraine hergeben würde hat also die nato
etwas falsch gemacht nein ich glaube die
nato überhaupt nichts falsch gemacht das
ist ein narrativ das einfach so nicht
stimmt also man muss ganz einfach sagen
ein beitritt der ukraine zur nato stand
nicht zur debatte zum zeitpunkt des
angriffskrieges von putin die ukraine
hat 2008 als kompromiss von merkel und
sarkozy diesen satz rein verhandelt
genau sagt dass sie diesen satz rein
verhandelt die ukraine und georgien
werden irgendwann man mitglied der nato
weil die alternative wäre gewesen dass
die damalige us administration den
membership action plan also die konkrete
vorbereitung für eine
nato-mitgliedschaft den georgien geben
wollte und dann auch den ukrainern geben
wollte so 2008
hat merkel verhindert mit sarkozy
generell hat hier neulich auch in
unserer sendung bestätigt wir haben
2022 die ukraine hat bis heute noch
nicht im membership action plan das
heißt es gab keine bewegung auf eine
ukrainische minato mitgliedschaft von
maja ist es einfach ein mythos der
sozusagen ich sage jetzt mal
entschuldigung herr von dohnanyi das
geht jetzt nicht persönlich gegen sie
aber es ist ein mythos der sozusagen von
den russen gespielt wird um zu sagen sie
werden konkret bedroht zweiter punkt
nato russland grund her also die
vereinbarung zwischen der nato und
russland 997 die nato sichert russland
zu keine permanente substanzielle
präsenz von kampftruppen der nato in den
neuen mitgliedstaaten substanziell heißt
5000 man hat sich geeinigt um russische
militär 5000 soldaten sind substanzielle
präsenz keine taktischen nuklearwaffen
auf den territorien neuen mitglieder
keine nato installationen sozusagen wie
headquarters oder so und auf den
territorien die nato hat sich bis heute
gehalten
die nato hat sich bis heute daran
gehalten also von daher dieses narrativ
die nato bereitet sich aus und bedroht
russland das stimmt einfach faktisch
nicht das stimmt einfach faktisch nicht
und von daher so gelang fällt das alles
zusammen und jetzt kommt der letzte
punkt entschuldigung herr von dohnanyi
anlehnung an die eu 2014 brach aus also
annexion der krim und sozusagen
unterstützung der separatisten in der
ausdruck reiner weil die gewählte
ukrainische regierung sich der eu
annähern wollte da spielte die nato
keine rolle das war der entscheidende
punkt warum putin land seine truppen in
marsch gesetzt hat also die nato ist ja
erst mal ganz weit draußen wenn man es
realistisch betrachtet sie ist nur sehr
sozusagen im russischen narrativ und
ihnen den aktiven die sozusagen die
russische position
multiplizieren spielt die nato eine
wesentliche rolle des johanniter nie
gespielt habe von dohnanyi keine
gegenrede
ja eine kurze gegenrede also das ist ja
alles ganz schön und richtig was sie
sagen nur übersehen sie offenbar das am
14 juni 2021 also vor knapp sieben
monaten oder so etwas die nato auf der
ebene der regierungschefs einen
einstimmigen beschluss gefasst hat die
ukraine wird in die nato kommen und das
war natürlich ein nach finde ich sehr
falsches signal in einer zeit in der man
ja so dass bereits sozusagen ein aufbau
auf der russischen seite war unter
diesem aspekt ich finde dass die
verhandlungen die man hätte führen
müssen hätten viel früher begonnen aber
warum schreibt bregenz geht den sie ja
auch canon vor sieben jahren es gibt
einen heißen krieg in europa wenn wir
die naht die ukraine in die nato
aufnehmen warum schreibt er dass warum
nennt denn burns der heutige chef in
diesem zusammenhang die aufnahme der
ukraine in die nato als eine heiße und
hellere linie rote linien russische
entfernen ist also im sie haben nicht
genug darüber nachgedacht welche
konsequenzen dort entsteht das ist der
punkt ich sage ja nicht dass das herrn
putin entschuldigt das ist nicht mein
punkt ich sage nur wir haben selber
nicht alles getan was wir hätten tun
können da statt das wirklich energisch
also herr von dohnanyi mit nachsicht
wenn ich ihnen da auch widerspreche aber
die kausalität ist doch gerade anders
herum natürlich sie ist doch gerade
andersherum wir haben einen heißen krieg
in europa trotz der zurückhaltung des
westens und der nato trotz der
bereitschaft mit putin zu reden wir
haben doch mit putin da sind doch
gespräche verhandlungen über jahre
geführt worden schauen sie sich doch
bitte nur an was nach 2001 linie sie
diese frage ja aber diese frage stand
doch überhaupt nicht auf der
tagesordnung das ist doch ein popanz der
da aufgebaut jährige von den ahnen
entschuldigung wenn ich jetzt mal so
deutlich sagen ich wollte ihn auch heute
abend kann ich habe ihr buch noch mal
zur vorbereitung gelesen von uns
eigentlich in vielen teilen gut aber ich
hätte nicht damit gerechnet dass wir
jetzt über dieses thema sprechen das ist
doch ein popanz der da aufgebaut wird um
diese nato-mitgliedschaft die baltischen
staaten sind in der nato und werden von
putin bisher nicht angegriffen man muss
sich doch heute umgekehrt die frage
stellen ob es nicht richtig gewesen wäre
2008 die ukraine in die nato aufzunehmen
diese kausalität die interessiert mich
viel mehr wenn wir sie aufgenommen
hätten wäre es wahrscheinlich zu diesem
konflikt gar nicht gekommen weil die
nato daneben genügend
abschreckungspotenzial auch in der
ukraine gehabt hätte gegen putin und
diese expansion andersherum wird doch
ein schuh daraus
der moment als olaf scholz bei vladimir
putin war und die pressekonferenz
gegeben hat war ein ganz klares signal
an putin die nato mitgliedschaft der
ukraine steht nicht auf der tagesordnung
scholz hat das damals sehr süffisant
auch verpackt in dem er gesagt hat
solange wir regieren aber das war ein
klares signal und wir wissen aus listen
aus heutiger sicht wissen wir dass putin
zu diesem zeitpunkt schon entschieden
war in diesen brutalen krieg zu ziehen
insofern sage ich auch sehr klar dass
egal was die nato gemacht hat und ich
bin da bin da sozusagen auch sehr klar
das ist ein russisches narrativ ist was
wir gerade immer wieder erleben und was
falsch ist aber die nato trifft an
dieser stelle keinerlei schuld das will
ich hier ganz klasse keine schuld gibt
auch keine veranstaltung
es gibt eine rede putins ein oder zwei
tage nach beginn des krieges glaube ich
und diese ganze nato geschichte ist der
nebel karte in der in dieser rede
spricht er der ukraine die staatlichkeit
ab er beschuldigt die bolschewiken 1917
einen massiven fehler gemacht zu haben
dieses kunstgebilde ukraine das aus
seiner sicht überhaupt nicht existieren
dürfte als staat als nationalstaat einen
kleinen russland nennt er es genau
geschaffen zu haben das ist der
eigentliche kann
darum sozusagen das ost putins sicht und
da spielt die nato eine sekundäre rolle
aus putins sicht hat dieser staat keine
existenzberechtigung und das hat er so
deutlich gesagt wir sind katja gloger
bei der frage die friedrich merz uns
indirekt geschenkt hat herr von dohnanyi
wir sind gleich noch mal bei ihnen in
bezug auf die ukraine hier wollen wir
die ukraine in die nato aufgenommen
wären sie jetzt nicht so allein wir sind
im herzen bei ihnen aber sie sind de
facto allein und sie bekommen eine
indirekte hilfe von uns und mehr können
wir nicht tun das ist die situation die
ukraine selbst ist ja ein schwieriges
land mit einer komplexen schwierigen
widersprüchlichen geschichte es war im
jahr 2008 nicht so dass die mehrheit der
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
mit mit fliegenden fahnen in die in dem
nato wollten ganz im gegenteil wir
hatten es dann bald mit einem
regierungschef zu tun ein regierungschef
letztlich von putins gnaden
janukowitsch der im mai dann im in der
revolution des meiden hinweggefegt wurde
und sich jetzt vielleicht hoffnung macht
zurückzukehren nach ihr also der weg der
ukraine richtung westen ist ein
komplizierter ein gewundener ein langer
aber es ist ein weg in die richtung
westen und dienen und die mitgliedschaft
in der nato ist dabei
keine bislang keine priorität gewesen
ich denke was wir unterschätzt haben es
wirklich massiv unterschätzt haben dann
ist die
ideologisierung des russischen
präsidenten die wir nachvollziehen
können eigentlich seit mindestens zehn
jahren
der westen ist der feind der gegner der
westen ist im grunde darauf aus russland
nicht nur klein zu halten zu demütigen
sondern letztlich sogar zu zerstören
alle bewegungen alle der bürger
demonstrationen sind dass das werk
westlicher geheimdienste vor allen
dingen der skater kommen sahen viele
verschwörungs erzählungen zusammen und
zugleich die wachsende überzeugung und
ich fürchte dass er glaubt was er sagt
die wachsende überzeugung dass russland
eine ganz eigene eigenständige
zivilisation ist dem westen sondern in
den orthodoxen
echten wahren werten die
opferbereitschaft patriotismus familie
dem dekadenten westen letztlich
überlegen und dass in der ukraine die er
als teil des russischen herz landes des
russischen imperiums sieht die ukraine
zahlt jetzt den preis als und der
außenminister der ukraine formuliert
dass auch vor allen dingen in richtung
deutschland
entweder wird deutschland eine führende
nation bei der unterstützung der ukraine
und den kampf gegen das russische böse
oder deutschland bekommt eine neue
historische schuld für verlorene leben
und zerstörte städte
die ukraine müssen weiter auch ohne
unsere hilfe kämpfen
wir stecken in einem furchtbaren dilemma
wir können ja nicht nichts tun es geht
nicht
für die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer nicht
aber auch um unserer selbst will wir
würden uns ja selbst verraten mit all
dem was sonst vielleicht und hoffentlich
irgendwie wirklich wichtig ist aber die
nato kann keinen krieg um die ukraine
führen sind die roten linien die gezogen
sind weil das escalation risiko so hoch
ist und weil wladimir putin ob uns das
nun gefällt oder nicht er hat nach wie
vor die eskalation skomina so schwierig
es sieht sein mag mit der militärischen
entwicklung so sehr die panzer im morast
stecken
und so
bewundernswert ja auch der widerstands
wille der menschen in der ukraine ist am
ende hat er hat nur die mir putin die
eskalation dominanz und dessen die an
der nato die andenken werden umso
grausamer sein wie viele menschen gibt
es in der spd glauben sie herr klingbeil
in ihrer partei die sagen mit jeder
waffe diesem feuer ich glaube das ist in
der spd wie gerade über alles zerreißt
die menschen genau dieser spagat wir
sehen die bilder und wir alle befürchten
doch dass die bilder und das was dort in
der ukraine passiert noch noch
furchtbarer werden kann und auch wird
die nächsten tage und wochen ja und und
auf der anderen seite ist es genau das
was troge angesprochen hat wir müssen
als politik auch den kühlen kopf
bewahren und uns fragen was kann
eigentlich der nächste schritt bedeuten
sich ich will ihnen ein stück weit
widersprechen wenn sie sagen wir lassen
die ukraine alleine weil wir als
deutschland ein starkes land sind was
die wirtschaftlichen hilfen angeht weil
wir finde ich zu recht auch ein
zulieferer sich für waffenlieferungen
entschieden haben aber natürlich ist
klar es gibt eine schwelle bei aller
emotionalität und bei all dem was ein
furchtbares zerreißt auch an bildern und
was man dort hört und was in diesem land
passiert es gibt eine verantwortung die
wir auch tragen über eine gewisse
schwelle nicht hinüber zu gehen und dann
nicht in einer situation zu finden wo
wir auf einmal im dritten weltkrieg sind
hermann seiler diese flugzeuge polnische
kampfflugzeuge über der ukraine
womöglich mit hilfe deutschlands also
von rammstein aus gestartet das ist
jetzt endgültig vom tisch haben sie also
sieht wohl so aus dass das endgültig vom
tisch ist ich meine das ist genau das
spannungsfeld das erklingen mal gesagt
hat also persönlich sage ich meine wenn
man diese kampfflugzeuge hätte liefern
wollen hätte man es im geheimen tun
sollen und das war sozusagen die erste
überlegung bisher borel
unglücklicherweise in der
pressekonferenz das große bombe hat
platzen lassen und seitdem ist verzeihen
sie mir das wort die schi einfach nur
tag für tag zu beobachten
da das jetzt raus ist dass diese
überlegungen da waren stellt wirklich
die lieferung egal ob sie jetzt über
polen geht oder über ramstein oder
irgendwo über stellt eine aus der
russischen perspektive natürlich eine
neue eskalationsstufe da wenn man sie im
geheimen geliefert hätte wäre das
vielleicht gut gegangen aber so ist wir
werden mehr und mehr eine indirekte
kriegspartei waffenlieferungen sind ja
ok aber wenn ich sage ukrainische
piloten kommen nach polen zum beispiel
das war die ursprüngliche und fliegen
von dort ins kampfgebiet ich meine ich
würde es punkte die nicht verübeln wenn
er sagt dann legen wir diese diese
flugfelder in schutt und asche mit dem
mix bevor die überhaupt starten können
die der bundesministerin hat es auch
bestätigt die vorbereitungen laufen wie
jetzt polen diese flugzeuge liefern
könnte natürlich gab es auch den blinken
autoren also us amerikanische
außenminister da sagen die das dann
sagen sie das darf uns nicht noch mal
passiert ist also als annalena baerbock
diesen satz gesagt hat kamen kurze zeit
später sozusagen präsident lula und hat
und kam mit dieser idee zu sagen ja wir
polen die funny mix aber wenig wenn sie
nach ramstein und die amerikaner können
gucken wie sie sich von dort dann
verfrachten und dann haben die
amerikaner auch sag jetzt mal kalte füße
bekommen ja weil es ist einfach zu
renato ist nicht geschlossen man hätte
das als geschlossene nato-aktion wenn
machen müssen die nato ist da nicht
geschlossen so bleibt das entweder bei
den polen hängen oder bei den
amerikanern hängen beides ist sehr
unglücklich wir sind ja von dohnanyi ich
dachte ich lese das nicht richtig eine
mehrheit der deutschen ist nach einer
meinungsumfrage für die lieferung von
offensivwaffen an die ukraine was
glauben sie wie kommt das ist es aus wut
ist es aus angst es ist aus woher kommt
das
ich vermute es ist dass solidarität wenn
man diese schrecklichen bilder sieht
möchte man ja irgendwie helfen aber ich
stimme all denen zu die hier eben darauf
hingewiesen haben dass wenn man so etwas
macht für eine flugzeug lieferung zum
beispiel auf indirektem wege die gefahr
überall besteht dass plötzlich die natur
selber einbezogen wird ich fand das was
frau gloge gesagt hat über den
hintergrund der ganzen situation so
überzeugend dass man eigentlich dem kaum
noch etwas hinzufügen kann nur eines
würde ich gerne doch noch mal sagen ich
glaube dass wir eine chance für
verhandlungen haben dass putin die
partei ist mit der wir verhandeln müssen
und dass diese verhandlungen ausgehen
sollten gegenwärtig von der position die
serien ski der präsident der ukraine
selber geäußert hat nämlich wir müssen
gar nicht in die nato wir können auch
mit neutralität leben das ist ein neuer
satz eine neue perspektive und ich finde
auf diesem hintergrund sollte man die
diplomatie nochmal aufnehmen ich hoffe
dass das genauso gesehen wird in
washington wo ich bisher in dieser frage
trotz vieler amerikanischer stimmen
keine zustimmung zu einer solchen
politik gesehen gut
geschlagen in einem namensartikel heute
im grunde das schweizer modell zu nehmen
vorher war immer von der finlandia
sierung der ukraine die rede sie haben
mir herr merz vor wenigen tagen auch
einen eingreifen der nato nicht
ausgeschlossen es gab diesen anschlag
auf ein atomkraftwerk in der nähe von
kiew und sie haben folgenden satz gesagt
wir hören noch mal rein es kann eine
situation geben in der dann auch die
nato entscheidungen treffen muss putin
zu stoppen
das ist ein trivialer satz würden sie
den heute noch mal so sagen oder sagen
sie nein das ist zu
habe das in dem zusammenhang gesagt dass
genau die roten linien überschritten
werden dass nämlich nato territorium
betroffen ist und deswegen ist das ein
trivialer satz
und das ist doch völlig klar und das ist
ja mein punkt auch putin hat im
augenblick noch großen respekt vor der
nato bei allem was uns da auch zum teil
unterscheidet das thema übrigens
gescheitert und der geschwätzigkeit
eines der betroffenen akteure auf
europäischer seite nicht bei der nato
sondern er hat bis jetzt die baltischen
staaten nicht angegriffen obwohl er mit
kaliningrad königsberg dort eine exklave
hat die russische staatsgebiet ist er
hat ja schon einmal die russischstämmige
bevölkerung in diesen drei staaten
adressiert als diejenigen die
schutzbefohlene sind für ihn das waren
dieselben töne wie in der ost ukraine
exakt derselbe musste aber da hat er
respekt und das ist die rote linie
man müsste die nato das ist vielleicht
auch noch eine interessante frage und
eine wahnsinnig schwere die an genauso
zerreißt dann müsste die nato in eine
auseinandersetzung mit putin gehen
selbst wenn er nicht auf dem gebiet der
nato eingreifen würde also wann hat die
nato sich entschieden in kampfeinsätze
zugehen
flugverbotszonen zu sichern das war in
srebrenica ist war in libyen kann es
also frage an den militär doch irgend
eine situation geben sie beschreiben
hier dass putin das durchaus so auslegen
kann was immer wir da machen kann es
eine situation geben wo wir nicht mehr
auf nato territorium sind und die nato
sich trotzdem lehrern müsste also
zunächst einmal ich bin ja kein militär
ich bin wissenschaftler
angefangen mit romanische philologie das
müssen sie hinterher nochmals residenz
bundeswehr gehören der bundeswehr
akademie gekommen sind
also es gibt keinen punkt wo man sagt da
muss die nato rein also so lange nicht
an das territorium eines nato mitgliedes
angegriffen wird was dein artikel 5
auslöst und dann wird es eine reaktion
geben muss die nato oder erstmal
überhaupt nicht rein aber so ein fallout
war ja so ein gedanke also was täten wir
wenn atomkraftwerke angegriffen werden
und damit automatisch auch naturgebiet
riecht wird und ich glaube das sagen in
so einer situation und man hat das
gesehen in den letzten monaten die nato
auch die amerikaner haben bisher immer
sehr besonnen reagiert ja also haben
sich nicht auf sozusagen diese putin
eskalationsspirale eingelassen sondern
haben immer bisher gesagt wir ignorieren
das mehr oder weniger also wir liefern
waffen was ja richtig ist wir können
noch mehr waffen liefern aber wir
sozusagen als nato oder die nato
verweigert sich dem versuch der russen
sie in diesem konflikt drei größten
flugverbotszone ja also in der neueren
zeit bosnien im irak durch die
amerikaner und durch die briten glaube
ich waren das auch noch im norden und im
süden und dann in libyen jetzt muss man
sagen diese drei flugverbotszonen die in
brasilien durch die nato das war alles
gegen militärisch unterlegenen gegner
ist der erste punkt der zweite punkt ist
boss ist ein sehr gutes beispiel für das
problem dass uns in der ukraine droht
auf der einen seite heißt eine
flugverbotszone man muss sozusagen alles
was zur luftverteidigung da ist von den
russen erst mal kalt machen bombardiert
radaranlagen luft verteidigungsanlagen
muss man alle erst mal platt machen und
einige sagen wenn man das über die
ukraine ausbreitet sind auf russischem
territorium
das heißt man muss ins russische
territorium rein und auch dort das
ausschalten wenn man das wirklich alles
unterdrücken will das heißt wir würden
einen krieg gegen russland führen
zweiter punkt ist dann aber die
flugverbotszone dann kommen die russen
möglicherweise und testen liegt in
bosnien hat das bedeutet dass wir glaube
ich sechs oder sieben serbische
flugzeuge abgeschossen haben aber auf
amerikanischer seite wohl auch flugzeuge
abgeschossen also sie haben dann einen
luftkampf in die russen die
flugverbotszone testen wollen jetzt
kommt das große problem das meiste in
der ukraine findet nicht über die luft
statt sondern über die schwere
artillerie und das war im osten genauso
unser problem also es gab mal einen
zeitpunkt wann gesagt hat die die samen
müssen ihre schwere artillerie in
irgendeinem umkreis rausholen und alles
was dann noch drin stand wurde
bombardiert weil wenn sie dass die
angriffe auf die städte stoppen wollen
müssen sie sozusagen die artillerie
stellungen bombardiert wir würden uns in
einem voll umfänglichen krieg in der
ukraine gegen russland wohl auf dem
boden auf dem boden auch noch weil nur
so zu sagen da das von der luft her zu
kontrollieren hilft den meisten menschen
auf dem boden nicht wahr so dann tun wir
das auch geklärt klingbeil die ukraine
also militärisch effektiv zu
unterstützen ihr effektiv zu helfen
ist eigentlich nicht möglich
wir unterstützen durch waffenlieferungen
ich glaube auch dass wir
unterstützen dadurch dass der westen
gerade geschlossen da steht wir
unterstützen durch jetzt drei
sanktionspaket die auf den weg gebracht
wurden wir unterstützen durch durch
druck den wir gerade auch richtung china
deutlich formulieren china ist ein ganz
wichtiger akteur in dieser frage auch
wir müssen den druck auf china so
erhöhen auch durch durch diplomatie und
durch gespräche dass man dass man hilft
russland zu vernunft zurück bot ihn zur
vernunft zu bringen also das sind alles
dinge die wir tun können aber noch
einmal ich bin auch dabei wir dürfen
auch diesen szenarien gar nicht in den
raum stelle ist dass das darf der
wissenschaftler tun aber ich finde wir
als politik müssen sehr vorsichtig sein
mit jedem satz den wir sprechen wir
reden gerade von einer situation die uns
in der politik nicht über monate
beschäftigen wird sondern ich rede hier
von jahren das was dort gerade
sicherheitspolitisch passiert wird uns
über jahre beschäftigen über jahre
werden wir konsequenzen in unserem
gesellschaftlichen zusammenlebens
spielen durch die situation die putin
gerade dort schafft und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass wir klar sind dass wir
konsequent sind aber dass wir auch immer
mit der stimme der vernunft sprechen und
deswegen bin ich komplett dagegen dass
wir diese ganzen drohszenarien in den
raum stellen weil das am ende auch
wieder vielleicht putin argumente
liefert noch stärker vorzugehen und noch
stärker zu können das sind ja nicht
szenarien sondern es sind die wünsche
der ukraine um das noch mal ganz
deutlich zu sagen rumsitzen sicherlich
basieren in deutschland darüber
nachdenken ob wir da mit der nato
eingreifen irgendeinen punkt und wenn
sie jetzt fragen noch mal hat man kann
das passieren mit der nato das ist eine
spannende frage aber es geht jetzt alle
drum putin jeden tag dazu zu bringen
dass er die waffen verschafft und sie
sagen nicht noch mal zieht er in
hörsälen ski sagt schützt unseren himmel
und habt bitte weniger bürokratische
einwände wir haben keine zeit steht dass
er diese position von hans ich verstehe
dass trotzdem noch mal bei aller
emotionalität wir müssen hier den klugen
ideen den kühlen kopf bewahren weil wir
auch verantwortung tragen für das was
die nächsten 10 15 jahre auf diesem
kontinent passiert wir sind heute
verbunden in litauen und zwar in der
stadt ruckler mit dangel andré er ist
oberstleutnant und der deutsche
kommandeur der nato eingreiftruppe da
1600 soldatinnen und soldaten aus sechs
nationen und 940 deutsche wenn ich mir
das richtig gemerkt habe einen guten
abend nach ruckler her andrea
guten abend auch berlin wie ist hier ist
die erste frage in litauen wie groß ist
die sorge vor einem übergreifen dieses
konfliktes auf die baltischen staaten
also erstmal muss man sagen die lage ist
hier wie wir zu sagen pflegen stabil wir
befinden uns in einem land der
europäischen union auf nato territorium
derzeit keine indikatoren einer erhöhten
bedrohung gegenüber litauen oder dem
baltikum
gleichwohl ist die stimmung hier in den
letzten zwei wochen
etwas angespannter als sie vielleicht
vor vier oder fünf wochen gewesen ist
wie ihr persönlich hier als im harz
robert bressons battle group leisten
hier insbesondere durch unsere präsenz
einen wesentlichen beitrag für eine
glaubhafte abschreckung und das tun wir
derzeit vor allem durch erhöhte
ausbildungs und übungsmöglichkeiten
350 deutsche soldatinnen und soldaten
kamen hinzu und zwar vor knapp drei
wochen wie gehen sie mit dieser
situation um sie können ja jetzt nicht
sagen das ist irgendwie normaler einsatz
oder eine normale einsatzsituation oder
sie verfolgen ja alle nachrichten ja
natürlich also wir verfolgen genau so
wie sie
aufmerksam die entwicklung tun das mit
masse natürlich auch über die medien
brauchen zusätzliche informationen die
wir tagtäglich unseren männern und
frauen zur verfügung stellen
um auch
gerüchten vorzubeugen
nutzen jede gelegenheit die männer und
frauen auch direkt zu adressieren als
vor zwei wochen der krieg
russlands gegen die ukraine begann haben
wir auch am nächsten tag hier
unmittelbar eine antreten der gesamten
battle group durchgeführt und ich habe
die männer und frauen persönlich
adressiert
gleichwohl die aktuelle lage schärft den
blick für den auftrag wir sind noch
konzentrierter als wir das vorher
gewesen sind die männer und frauen gehen
mit der bedrohungslage sicherlich alle
individuell oben ein intensiverer
austausch sicherlich auch mit den
familien freunden und verwandten zu
hause und auch unser militär fahrer und
der truppen psychologe vor ort werden
hier deutlich häufiger in anspruch
genommen heißt das vielleicht vor drei
oder vier wochen der fall sei bereit
die der inspekteur des heeres hat gesagt
generalleutnant meist das deutsche heer
steht überwiegend nackt da haben ihre
soldatinnen und soldaten in alles was
sie brauchen also
erst mal stehen die worte meines
inspekteurs für sich die werde ich hier
auch nicht näher kommentieren
aber
gleichwohl kann ich sagen wir sind hier
als battle group gut ausgebildet und
haben alles was wir brauchen aber ist
auch richtig und wichtig zu wissen dass
wir uns hier mehr als ein jahr gezielt
auf den auftrag vorbereiten konnten und
unser personal und material kommt aus
der gesamten ersten deutschen
panzerdivision fühlen sich die litauer
von ihnen geschützt
definitiv die litauer sind froh und
dankbar dass wir hier sind
wir leisten hier einen wichtigen beitrag
für die verteidigung des landes wir sind
hier tief integriert
rhetorische strukturen wir unterstehen
ja einer literarischen brigade
und sind gemeinsam mit den litauern und
auch unseren partnern und alliierten
darauf vorbereitet letztlich das zu tun
was man hier von uns erwartet nämlich
ein beitrag zur verteidigung des landes
zu leisten
wir bedanken uns nach ruckler und vor
allen dingen mit freundlichen sehr
lieben herzlichen grüßen zu ihrer truppe
das war oberstleutnant daniel andrä der
kommandeur der nato eingreiftruppe in
litauen und damit sind wir herr merz bei
der großen frage was die bundeswehr
gerade braucht 100 milliarden hat sie
bekommen
soll sie bekommen ein sogenanntes
sondervermögen
in der partei der sozialdemokratie
rumort ist ordentlich wie man diese 100
milliarden jetzt aufteilt und ob da auch
noch ein bisschen entwicklungshilfe
dabei ist und andere sachen mehr für die
cdu csu ist das unstreitig dass das
alles in die bundeswehr geht naja wir
wollen zunächst mehr wissen als nur die
regierungserklärung des kanzlers vom
vorletzten sonntag der hand es ist gutes
recht aber naja also die ankündigung hat
ja sehr viel zustimmung gefunden auch
bei uns auch dass wir jetzt dieses zwei
prozent ziel
einhalten wollen sofort das sind
gewaltige summen die da aufgebracht
werden müssen für ausrüstung und
aufrüstung der bundeswehr
der bundeskanzler will das mit einer
grundgesetzänderung verbinden wir warten
auf die dokumente auf die unterlagen
soll wohl nächste woche ins
bundeskabinett und da werden wir das
beraten ich habe gesagt wir können uns
das vorstellen wir halten das ziel für
richtig aber über den weg dorthin müssen
wir noch reden grottenschlecht würden
sie wahrscheinlich sagen zum zustand der
bundeswehr
kommen sie auf die chance es gab dann
sagen
könnte die sehr grottenschlechte zustand
auch damit zu tun haben das ist 16 jahre
verteidigungsminister aus der cdu
also wenn wir so anfangen dann sage ich
in den letzten 19 von 23 jahren war die
spd in der regierung hat den
bundeskanzler gestellt und viele jahre
den bundesfinanzminister also
wenn sie wollen machen wir das dann
stellen wir die listenwahl zusammen
werde wofür verantwortung getragen hatte
wir wollen jetzt dafür sorgen dass das
nach vorne besser wird und dann sind wir
bei annette schaffung verändern ja vor
allen dingen touren ich will zwei punkte
sorgen vor immer das eine ist es geht
nicht nur um geld sondern es geht auch
um die ganzen beschaffungsvorhaben und
auch über die beschaffungs methode wie
das gemacht wird wenn das weiter so
gemacht wird wie in der vergangenheit
dann werden 100 milliarden nicht helfen
dann bleiben die da ziemlich lange
liegen zumal wenn sie gar nicht haben
der nächste punkt ist und er ist noch
wichtiger frieden und freiheit kann man
nicht kaufen es gibt es nicht im
supermarkt wo sie mal ans regal gehen
und sagen das hole ich mir da jetzt mal
raus da da muss eine haltung dazu kommen
da muss eine grundsätzliche einstellung
dazu kommen und die muss sich auch jetzt
nicht nur in dieser krisensituation
zeigen wo da die bomben fallen und wo
diese schrecklichen bilder durch das
fernsehen gehen wenn der schlachtenlärm
mal abnimmt und wenn die bilder mal
nicht mehr jeden abend im fernsehen sind
dann muss das bleiben und zwar für viele
jahre und das ist ein stück auch unserer
unserer haltung zu diesen themen auch zu
dieser frage wie verteidigen wir
eigentlich unsere freiheit klaus von
dohnanyi noch mal die frage nach hamburg
muss deutschland um auch zu beschreiben
wie groß diese wende diese wende in der
deutschen verteidigungspolitik war muss
deutschland im denken zurückkehren zu
diesem gleichgewicht des schreckens zu
der abschreckung die wir eigentlich
dachten
verabschieden zu können
nein dazu muss deutschland in keiner
weise zurückkehren deutschland muss
verteidigungs bereit sein und wenn die
bundeswehr nicht entsprechend
ausgerüstet ist oder ausgebildet ist
muss das geändert werden aber ich
widerspreche ausdrücklich der these von
herrn merz das in erster linie wie eine
haltung brauchen die sage ich mal
militärisch ausgerichtete wir brauchen
eine haltung die auf frieden
ausgerichtet ist wir brauchen eine
haltung die auf verhandlungen und auf
ausgleich ausgerichtet ist wir brauchen
eine haltung die die interessen der
anderen seite jeweils mit einbezieht in
unsere eigenen interessen die zukunft
liegt nicht beim militär
die zukunft liegt in der diplomatie die
was militär bedeuten kann das sieht man
gegenwärtig in der ukraine
was verhandlungen bedeuten könnten das
haben wir leider nicht gesehen wir
brauchen eine diplomatische
außenpolitik und willy brandt hat mal
gesagt und ich möchte das ausdrücklich
zitieren
außenpolitik soll eine art generalstabs
arbeit am frieden seien die außenpolitik
muss auf den frieden ausgerichtet sein
und das ist die entscheidende haltung
die wir brauchen zu randzeiten dass wir
gleichzeitig
habe ich die verteidigung zu und
insofern hatte willy brandt
offensichtlich einen anderen hintergrund
erklingen bei sie müssen uns erklären
wie sie mit den empörten traurigen
wütenden zornigen sozialdemokraten
umgehen die sagen wir können jetzt 100
milliarden in die verteidigung wenn die
verteidigung packen
verteidigungsausgaben wenn wir noch so
viele andere sachen zu lösen haben gehen
diese 100 milliarden sondern vermögen
tatsächlich eben die bundeswehr dass der
bundeskanzler so angekündigt ich habe
wenn märz vernommen dass er auch sagt
das unterstützen wir brauchen eine zwei
drittel mehrheit dafür und das werden
wir so tun als 100 100 jahren die als
sondervermögen für die ausstattung der
bundeswehr zur verfügung gestellt werden
das ist das was wir vorhaben und nochmal
ich glaube das sollten wir auch ohne
parteipolitische scharmützel sollten wir
das tun jetzt kann man darüber streiten
ob in den letzten jahren zu wenig
gemacht wurde ich bin seit 2009
verteidigungsausschuss ich sage schon da
ist zu wenig getan worden das können wir
vielleicht auch überparteilich
feststellen und ich will aber einmal
diesen spagat auflösen weil ich glaube
es geht nicht um die frage machen wir
internationale diplomatie und
friedensverhandlungen oder machen wir
bundeswehr ich glaube dass wir uns
bewusst machen dass die eigene stärke
die grundlage dafür ist das überhaupt in
verhandlung mit leuten wie putin
eintreten können und ich sage schon und
das nochmal ich lasse die parteipolitik
raus aber wir müssen feststellen dass
wir auch seit 2010 vielleicht auf einem
trip waren wo wir landes und
bündnisverteidigung zuviel
vernachlässigt haben wo wir darüber
diskutiert haben ob es eher um den grill
ja einsatz in afghanistan geht um den
häuserkampf in nordafghanistan um diese
dinge und das sind ja die ganzen
strategischen debatten sie wissen das
besser als ich aber die auch im
verteidigungsausschuss im
verteidigungsministerium geführt worden
und das ist doch die erkenntnis aber
noch einmal es geht nicht darum jetzt zu
sagen internationale diplomatie und
völkerrecht und regelbasierte ordnung
ist gescheitert sondern es geht darum zu
sagen die eigene stärke auch einen
starken bundeswehr aber auch sozusagen
starke institutionen starke diplomatie
stark entwicklungs aber das ist die
grundvoraussetzung dafür dass wir
international verhandeln die lateiner
hat immer gesagt haben
du den frieden willst planer den krieg
könnten wir deutschland denn
konventionell ausstatten so ausstatten
dass wladimir putin das als abschreckung
empfinden würde nein darum geht es ja
nicht und das konnte die bundeswehr auch
im kalten krieg nicht auch wenn sie
500.000 mann stark weil die bundeswehr
wäre auch im kalten krieg nie in der
lage gewesen das territorium des viel
kleineren bundesrepublik deutschland
damals alleine zu verteidigen es ist ein
mix größte sie ist ein gesunder in
deutschland und könnte man europa so
konventionell aufrüsten dass wir für
wladimir putin eine bedrohung darstellen
würden wir folgen der idee von herrn mag
so kommt der punkt wir wussten nicht auf
wir aus das heißt aus genau wie
beschaffen sozusagen der bundeswehr das
was sie braucht und wir fangen nicht an
ihn eine rüstungsspirale einzutreten ich
werde sicherlich jetzt keine sympathien
bekommen wenn ich sage wenn man diese
100 milliarden mal sehr realistisch
betrachtet und mit den
verteidigungshaushalt und mit dem was
wir der nato versprochen haben über
jahre was aufgrund dieses komplizierten
deutschen prozesses mit dem
haushaltsausschuss und dann sozusagen
mit der mittelfristigen finanzplanung
und so was nie richtig unterfüttert
werden konnten dann schmelzen diese 100
milliarden relativ schnell ab zu einem
betrag der noch immer sehr gut ist wer
aber der nicht dafür sorgen wird dass
wir demnächst in fünf jahren eine armee
sind vor den chinesen oder selbst die
amerikaner die knie zittern sondern
kann auch nicht die absicht sagen wir
werden im besten falle wenn alles gut
läuft ich glaube da gibt es noch viele
nüsse zu knacken aber wenn alles gut
läuft dann wird es eine bundeswehr geben
die das hat was sie braucht um ihren
auftrag zu erfüllen und das ist ein
auftrag ist nicht alleine deutschland
genau nicht alles für den rest der welt
sondern es ist ein teil einer großen
auftritt der nato auch der europäischen
und genau und ich finds dennoch eine
traurige vorstellung meinen töchtern
erklären zu müssen dass man jetzt wieder
mehr militärisch oder auch in
militärischen kategorien denken muss und
möglicherweise sogar
handeln muss und ich kann mich dann
eigentlich immer nur ein bisschen
festhalten
an der harmel doktrin von vielen längst
vergessen in den 60er jahren wer einmal
aufgestellt die gesagt hat wir müssen
beides tun wir müssen sagen eindämmen
und gleichzeitig aber immer die tür und
wie offen halten zur verhandlung in dem
sarah ist natürlich auch es ist sowieso
keinen gegensatz die frage ist werden
wir also es gibt alternative vorschläge
sigmar gabriel glaube ich hat immer
gesagt klar sollten wir die zwei prozent
erfüllen 1,5 prozent nehmen will für uns
und 0,5 prozent geben sie den
osteuropäern ben hodges hat
interessanterweise nichts anderes gesagt
auch in dieser sendung und vorgeschlagen
paktes in die infrastruktur und in die
bahngleise damit wir mit dem
militärgerät gegebenenfalls dahin kommen
wo wir kommen wollen also die diskussion
ist ja die frage wieweit definieren wir
verteidigung
und die andere frage ist den ukrainern
hilft jetzt auch nicht und in unsere in
dieser situation hilft es uns jetzt auch
nicht aber sie sind auch der überzeugung
wir müssen über diese abschreckungs
kategorien wieder reden wir brauchen sie
weil wir es mit despoten darüber
nachdenken wir müssen darüber reden und
wir müssen glaube ich als als
gesellschaft die wir ja nun doch auch
friedens verwöhnt waren zwar nun endlich
isch's privileg für mindestens eine
generation
dass man über krieg oder oder richtig
richtig tiefe krise nicht wirklich
nachdenken musste klima ein anderes
thema
diese zeiten sind vorbei und
darüber eine kluge debatte zu führen
nicht aufgeregt und über lange zeit
auch geduldig zu lernen das glaube ich
eine große aufgabe für unsere
gesellschaft um diese
resilienz zu entwickeln und gleichzeitig
nun doch zu den entscheidenden werten zu
stehen die wir uns auf die fahnen
geschrieben haben und dazu gehört was
man menschenwürde zu tun und mit
empathie und mit ein paar grundsätzen so
und unsere empathie zeigen wir und tun
das auch schon in einem größten ausmaß
und in einem wünschenswert großem ausmaß
weil wir flüchtlinge in deutschland
haben die mittlerweile
empfangen betreut werden und vor allen
dingen auch in berlin in größenordnung
angekommen sind logischerweise ich
begrüße jetzt hier in berlin katja
kipping von den linken noch keine drei
monate im amt als sozialsenatorin frank
giering an den guten abend zu ihnen
vielleicht darf ich auch sie als erstes
mit dieser frage konfrontieren wie
erschrocken wie entsetzt waren sie als
dieser krieg begannen sie in den
freiwilligen jahr in der nähe von moskau
verbracht glaube ich sie haben eine enge
beziehung zu diesem land
ja also es ist am wochenende mit meiner
tochter das ende der olympia angeschaut
habe hatte ich so eine sorge und dachte
wenn jetzt so lumpi vorbei ist wird
womöglich die hemmung abnehmen bei putin
dass die ukraine anzugreifen und ich
habe daraufhin einen krisenstab
gesprochen und wir haben entschieden
dass wir jetzt sofort szenarien in
erfahrung bringen was das bedeutet auch
was an fluchtbewegung das auslösen wird
weil für mich als landespolitikerin war
klar also
wenn wenn hier die ukraine angegriffen
wird wird das entsprechend menschen die
flucht jagen und dann haben wir
natürlich eine aufgabe voller mitgefühl
und mit offenen herzen zu reagieren und
dafür sorge zu tragen dass die menschen
die vor bomben und scharfschützen in der
ukraine fliehen müssen auch entsprechend
aufgenommen werden und mein zweiter
gedanke und mein zweiter mein zweiter
gedanke war weil ich auch hier russische
freunde habe meine große sorge dass all
die abscheu all der wut den wir auf
putin haben und seine regierung dass der
hier dann in der stadt berlin auch
russischsprachige menschen trifft und
mich berührt das wirklich wenn ich höre
wie auch kinder mit russischem
hintergrund auf dem schulhof dafür
angegriffen werden wir müssen auch
aufpassen dass der hass den putin sieht
jetzt hier nicht ausgebeutet werden muss
von menschen die auch mit ihm nicht
einverstanden sind aber zufällig
dieselbe sprache sprechen zwei millionen
insgesamt sagt die un in berlin sind
jetzt 100000 knapp 100000 angekommen
wenn diese zeit der kuscheltiere und es
heißen kaffees und des ersten findens
der unterkünfte vorbei ist wer kümmert
sich dann frau kipping wer kümmert sich
darum dass die kinder in der schule sind
das die eltern arbeit finden
ich glaube das hat man in den letzten
tagen ganz gut in berlin gesehen das ist
natürlich eine gemeinsame
kraftanstrengung von zivilgesellschaft
von land und es brauche auch eine
bundesweite solidarität und ich würde
das gerne auch mal ein bisher sind zwei
millionen glaube es werden noch viel
mehr werden und wir stehen hier am
anfang der womöglich größten flucht
bewegungen in europa seit ende des
zweiten weltkrieges und berlin ist das
tor für diese flüchtlinge zu westeuropa
und die menschen kommen mit zügen mit
bussen sie können ja zum glück visafrei
einreisen
und wir haben hier eine situation also
die ganze nacht seit beginn des krieges
muss ich sagen ist jeder tag und jede
nacht für mein team für den krisenstab
aber auch für die vielen ehrenamtlichen
in berlin ein wettlauf und zwar im
wettlauf zwischen der zahl der
unterkünfte die mannschaft und der
steigenden anstiegs zahlen und das
schlimme ist wir sind erst am anfang er
klingt es wenn die regierende
bürgermeisterin franziska gefalle sagt
es ist jetzt übrigens eng hier und wir
brauchen die hilfe des bundes dann
reagiert der bund auch ich bin schon am
anfang sagen dass ich vor dem was katja
kipping franziska giffey was die ganze
stadt berlin und auch die ehrenamtlichen
hier leisten ich hab da ein wahnsinns
respekt vor und ich bin dankbar und ja
es ist eine situation die
die wir gemeinsam schaffen müssen nancy
faeser bereitet das auch schon seit
langem vor mit den ländern aber
natürlich ist ist so dass erstmal berlin
für viele der anlaufpunkt war und das
ist eine situation die wir jetzt aber in
den griff kriegen und wo wir dann auch
mit den anderen bundesländern gucken
müssen dass wir die situation meistern
der bund noch mal ist da ganz klar mit
in der verantwortung aber es ist eine
situation die uns alle jetzt fordert die
wir auch gemeinsam hinkriegen von
dohnanyi wenn sie diese bilder sehen
denken sie dann an das jahr
1945 oder denken sie an das jahr 2015
ich denke mit erinnerung an das jahr
1945 an das jahr 2015
und oder sogar weiter voraus ich glaube
dass wir eine unglaubliche
flüchtlingswelle bekommen werden und
was in der diskussion hier noch gar
keine rolle gespielt hat aber was ich
doch für sehr bedeutsam halte
gleichzeitig und dann drücken wir ja
faktisch die ganze debatte über das
klima und über die klimafolgen und die
flüchtlings ergebnisse die auch aus der
klimaveränderung erfolgen werden
wir haben durch diesen krieg sozusagen
uns eigentlich von dem wichtigsten thema
das die menschheit und dass auch wir
deutsche haben abgewendet
das ist ein weiterer grund warum ich der
meinung bin wir müssen unbedingt
verhandlungen auch mit putin führen und
den versuch machen auf diese weise doch
am ende den krieg zu stoppen und keiner
wünscht sich das nicht genau so wie sie
hunderttausende sind gekommen es werden
immer mehr werden herr merz müsste man
jetzt nicht nur ein sondervermögen für
die deutsche bundeswehr sondern auch ein
sondervermögen flüchtlingshilfe
verlangen also wir haben ja erfahrungen
aus dem jahr 2015 16 auch schlechte
erfahrungen gemacht
wir sind im augenblick zu recht erneut
stolz darauf dass wir so viel engagement
in der bevölkerung sehen auch der
hilfsorganisationen
die das wirklich toll machen aber das
muss natürlich alles trotzdem
organisiert werden und es muss vor allen
dingen registriert werden
anders als die flüchtlinge die wir 2015
16 hatten haben die flüchtlinge die
jetzt kommen visafreiheit sie haben auch
aufenthaltsrecht in deutschland aber ich
finde wir müssen trotzdem wissen wer da
kommt
wir haben hier die berechtigte vermutung
dass das nicht nur flüchtlinge aus der
ukraine sind und deswegen fände ich wäre
die bundesregierung gut beraten jetzt
hier sehr schnell auch dafür zu sorgen
dass eine registratur stattfindet fragen
wir gleich katja das ist ein wichtiger
punkt denn wissen wie wir kommen wir
kommen wenn die zahlen die frau kipping
hier genannt hat richtig sind und nicht
teile die einschätzung
dann werden wir hier eine enorme
belastung für die bevölkerung haben das
ist im augenblick noch sehr positiv es
wird im augenblick noch sehr positiv
auch von den menschen angenommen und
aufgenommen aber wenn die zahlen so groß
werden dann haben wir hier relativ
schnell eine hohe last und die geht dann
insbesondere zu lasten der städte und
gemeinden flüchtlinge weil es einfach
nicht aufgenommen werden er muss höre
ich da eine neue obergrenze herren
überhaupt nicht ganz im gegenteil wir
haben da eine große humanitäre
verpflichtung aber das muss alles ein
bisschen organisiert und auch gesteuert
werden und deswegen ist mein punkt
zuallererst wir müssen mal register
gewinnt wissen wir was weiß die stadt
berlin über die flüchtlinge die da
kommen
und es sind so habe ich gelesen in aller
erster linie ist es ukrainische
mittelschicht was wissen sie über die
menschen die hier ankommen also ein
großteil kommt natürlich erstmal
visafreies reisen da ein großteil es
immer noch privat untergebracht bei
verwandten und bekannten und wir können
deren daten erst aufnehmen wenn die sich
dann registrieren als kriegsflüchtlinge
aber ich habe ja mit verschiedenen
gesprochen und will mal so zwei
schlaglichter geben also wo laut ja so
besser die erst den ersten satz den er
zu mir gesagt hat bitte bitte gebt uns
hier schnell eine arbeitserlaubnis
für mich als ukraine ist es
unvorstellbar einfach mit den händen in
schuss dazusitzen ich will mich hier
einbringen und ich habe mehrere leute
gesprochen die haben berufsausbildung
und und und also wir reden die ganze
zeit von fachkräftemangel das ist
sozusagen wir können über diese menschen
nicht nur als belastung reden sondern
wir müssen über die heißen gewinn reden
der zweite person mit der ich gesprochen
habe war es an einer mutter von drei
kindern ihr mann hat die familie an die
grenze gefahren musste danach
zurückfahren die ist jetzt mit den
kindern bei uns in berlin untergebracht
und sie sagt mir zeigte mir auf dem
handy fotos und bilder wie sie auch
bomben einschüsse bei ihrer flucht schon
erlebt haben und sie sagt mir diese drei
kinder die fordern die ganze zeit
aufmerksamkeit
sie ist selber natürlich unglaublich
angespannt weil sie sorge um ihren mann
hat die brauchen jetzt natürlich auch
eine beschäftigung und eine betreuung
aber ich muss noch eine botschaft
loswerden weil ich freue mich sehr was
laut class mit lars klingbeil zu
bundesweiten verantwortung gesagt hat
und ich hatte mir auch fest vorgenommen
jetzt nur produktiv nach vorne zu
schauen nachdem am anfang ich das gefühl
hatte man muss die bundesregierung erst
wach rütteln aber ich habe wenige
minuten vor dieser sendung eine
nachricht bekommen wo ich sein muss ich
bin fassungslos wir haben in berlin
wirklich die situation dass sich ein
großteil der ankünfte auf berlin
konzentriert und das führt auch den
großen hauptbahnhof manchmal wirklich an
die grenze dessen was an schierer
menschenmasse noch es möglich ist zu
bewältigen
und deswegen werden wir seit tagen dafür
dass zum beispiel busse die kommen dass
sie nicht erst mal nach berlin kommen wo
dann die menschen nachts aussteigen und
erstmal in der stadt untergebracht
werden müssen sondern dass man die
womöglich in eine andere stadt fährt ich
weiß aus anderen städten wird warten
gemeinden darauf den menschen zu helfen
ich habe von meinem krisenstab chef
gehört dass heute das bmi wider 17 busse
mit a 60 leuten aus polen direkt nach
berlin leitet anstatt die woanders sind
weiter zu leiten wo es auch noch mal
eine ganz andere
unterbringungsmöglichkeiten gibt und ich
glaube da ist der ernst der lage noch
nicht überall verstanden auch nicht
angekommen erklingen bei muster sofort
sagen frage von friedrich merz an sie
wird die stadt berlin organisieren dass
es auch eine registrierung der menschen
wir haben ja schon längst wir haben ja
schon längst mit der registrierung
angefangen aber nochmal das sind
visafreiheit wo wissen wir leben nicht
einen überwachungsstaat
touristen können wir nicht registrieren
aber wir helfen jeden der an kommt der
kommt eine unterkunft und natürlich
beginnt schon die registrierung das ist
in unserem eigenen anliegen aber wir
brauchen die rechtsgrundlage vom bund
dafür auch da braucht es eine
rechtsgrundlage erklingen weil sie
vertreten hier die ampel sie dürfen
jetzt aber gleich nach vorne sagen es
wird zu rechtsgrundlagen dafür geben und
es würden ordentlichen verteilung geben
und sie kriegen noch die frage von mir
wer sagt jetzt eigentlich wir schaffen
das
erstens noch mal ich kann jetzt zu der
konkreten situation die katja kipping
beschrieben hat nicht sagen aber ich
nehme das an dieser stelle mit und ich
habe vorher ja gesagt es geht um eine
faire verteilung die wir in deutschland
brauchen da sind alle 16 bundesländer in
der pflicht berlin leistet da gerade
wahnsinnig viel ich hab den tiefen
respekt vor aber das muss sich ändern
zweites registrierung jahr brauchen wir
aber die problematik auch im
aufenthaltsstatus hat kipping
beschrieben aber trotzdem wird das ja
danach kommen und ich werde morgen bei
mir im wahlkreis sein wir haben die
größte flüchtlingsunterkunft in
niedersachsen grundwert mit genau das
bild auch vor ort verschaffen wo die
probleme sind noch mal wir sind in einer
situation dass muss ich ihn anrufen
ausgelöst durch ein krieg den wladimir
putin begonnen den haben wir alle nicht
gewollt dass jetzt gerade viele menschen
die vertrieben werden in ihre heimat die
kommen nach deutschland wir haben eine
solidarität
ich glaube sie damals gefragt wer sagt
den spruch beschaffen da ist ja ich wir
haben jetzt eine gemeinsame
verantwortung herr merz auch an dieser
stelle dass wir hier auch in einem
politischen konsens uns fest verabreden
dass wir diese situation meistern
arrangement übt das wir flüchtlinge
verteilen müssen wir haben schon mal
geübt das ist ganz gut wäre auch zu
wissen wer kommt und wir sollten an
gewissen erfahrungsschatz ab weil du mit
dem konsens von immer das ist alles gut
und schön aber die verantwortung liegt
bei der bundesregierung und wir haben
einen bundes innenministerin die zurzeit
alle bundesinnenminister auf die zinne
bringt weil sie nichts tut
abstimmung mit 16 16 tagen läuft die
länder alle alle auf der zinne weil sie
von der bundesinnenministerium karnische
bekommen das können sie ändern ändern
sie ist aber keine frage des konsens ist
das müssen sie also gerade trägt berlin
eine hauptforderung deshalb gelingt es
gibt glaube ich ein paar unionsgeführte
bundesländer die durchaus 16 umgehen und
minister haben ihnen das schon
aufgeschrieben ministerpräsidenten haben
rechten vorbereitet sein sie sind noch
nicht so beansprucht wie berlin
beansprucht ist ich darf mich an der
stelle jetzt nicht verabschieden weil
wir sind noch ein bisschen ich wollte
nur die chance nutzen unbedingt darauf
hinzuweisen dass den menschen in aller
erster linie natürlich eine physische
unterstützung gilt und jede sachspende
aber vor allen dingen geld es ist heute
ein großer ein besonderer tag der tag
der ukraine im zdf und wir möchten sie
bitten wenn sie spenden wollen dann an
dieses aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
die iban ist 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
das stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine und
es sind insgesamt an diesem abend schon
über 93 millionen euro
zusammengekommen und dafür natürlich
unseren herzlichsten dank wir sind hier
wieder zurück bei den harten themen in
der runde und sagen der preis der
freiheit muss noch thematisiert werden
ich zitiere christian gentner wie hoch
darf der eigentlich steigen wir haben es
in deutschland mit dem ergebnis von
sanktionen zu tun die preise steigen
us präsident biden verkündet ein energie
embargo
wir verbieten die einfuhr von öl gas und
energie aus russland
das problem ist dass wenn wir das tun
und die lieferketten reißen dann reden
wir nicht über autofreie sonntag oder so
etwas sondern dann reden wir über
schwere schädigungen des
wirtschaftlichen kreislauf über
arbeitslosigkeit über große
gesellschaftliche schäden und dann ist
die frage halten wir das durch ein
moralisches dilemma wie viel
lebensstandard opfern wir für die
ukraine wenn wir die gas und öl importe
weiter betreiben dann finanzieren wir
auf rekordniveau den krieg von putin
gegen das ukrainische volk mit annähernd
eine milliarde dollar pro tag das kann
nicht sein damit konterkarieren wir
unsere eigenen sanktionen
röttgens parteifreund tobias hans kämpft
auch für moral die der deutschen
autofahrer
morgen ich bin jetzt hier gerade an der
tankstelle vorbei gefahren ist es
wirklich
frei eur 12 ich finde da ist jetzt
wirklich ein punkt erreicht wo man sagen
muss da muss mal an der stadt bereichert
sich an diesen gestiegenen energiekosten
deswegen habe ich die herzliche bitte
unterstützt mich dabei jetzt wirklich
die stimme laut zu machen gegenüber der
bundesregierung des brit preis bleiben
sie die muss jetzt her
damit sind wir bei friedrich merz märz
in norbert röttgen fordert dass wir die
komplett die energieimporte aus russland
stoppen fordern sie das jetzt auch wir
haben uns gestern in einer mehrstündigen
fraktionsvorstand sitzung wird dieser
frage intensiv befasst und kommen
gemeinsam und übereinstimmt zu einem
anderen ergebnis
wir sind in einer situation die anders
ist als die der vereinigten staaten von
amerika wir können insbesondere das gas
das wir aus russland bekommen nicht
ersetzen jedenfalls nicht vollständig
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt amerika hat öl
importe aus russland die sie fast sofort
und vollständig zum beispiel aus
südamerika einsetzen können wir können
das nicht insofern teilen wir diese
auffassung gemeinsam nicht wir haben
gesagt man könnte zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
nord stream 1 stoppen dann hätten wir
aber immer noch gas genug für die
versorgung der deutschen volkswirtschaft
ist würde eingeschränkt aber wir hätten
genug es wäre vor allem dem ziel gedient
und nur diesem ziel gedient diesen krieg
jetzt mit härtesten sanktionen die wir
uns auch leisten können müssen zu
stoppen aber wir haben natürlich
trotzdem auswirkungen wir sehen die
spritpreise tobias hat das völlig zu
recht gesagt gibt es möglichkeiten das
zu tun erleben sie das in der jetzigen
lage angemessen zu sagen da reicht ein
punkt unter der zusammenhang stimmt ja
so je höher die spritpreise sind je
höher sind die mehrwertsteuer einnahmen
des staates da liegen 19 prozent
mehrwertsteuer obendrauf allem und je
höher die spritpreise steigen je höher
ist der angriff der sind die einnahmen
bei der mehrwertsteuer und dann haben
wir gestern gesagt das könnte man jetzt
auf 7 prozent reduzieren dass wir ein
ungefähr 20 cent pro liter und wenn man
bereit wäre auch die mineralölsteuer
heute heißt die energie steuer auch noch
mal zu reduzieren für eine gewisse zeit
dann könnte es noch mal 20 cent sein
also der staat könnte zurzeit was tun
das ist unser vorschlag eeg-umlage kommt
ja auch unser vorschlag macht die
koalition
wir gehen jetzt noch einen schritt
weiter und sagen warum entlasten wir da
jetzt nicht insbesondere diejenigen die
an der tankstelle stehen das sind ja
nicht nur die privaten autofahrer
sondern das sind handwerksbetriebe die
einfach jetzt auch entlastet werden
müssten endet die solidarität der
autofahrer denken sie bei zwei euro
fünfzig weiß ich nicht das weiß niemand
von uns aber das wird kritisch das ist
sehr teuer und das ist insbesondere für
diejenigen teuer die in ihren betrieben
fahrzeuge brauchen die betriebe haben wo
autos gebraucht werden wo kleine
transporter gebraucht werden dass ganzen
transportgewerbe ist in einer äußerst
kritischen situation da finde ich könnte
man jetzt helfen katja gloger robert
habeck fans vor dem sozialen frieden
oder besser gesagt fürchtet um den
sozialen frieden in diesem land und vor
gravierenden auswirkungen auf die
deutsche wirtschaft wir reden nicht über
den autofreien sonntag sondern über
gravierende auswirkungen auf die
deutsche wirtschaft so sanktionen muss
man durchhalten weiß jetzt nicht ob man
für die freiheit unbedingt frieren muss
vielleicht reich die aldi hat heute die
heizung ein bisschen runter zu drehen
aber es ist natürlich eine illusion zu
glauben dass das härteste sanktionspaket
dass die eu die vereinigten staaten
andere länder jemals eigentlich verhängt
haben mir ist kein anderes bekannt dass
in seiner schnelligkeit und härte
verhängt wurde und ja auch wirkung zeigt
gegen russland als wichtigen
rohstofflieferanten es ist eine illusion
zu glauben dass
das wir nicht auch langen teil dieses
preises bezahlen und auch da gilt es
glaube ich in diesem dilemma stecken
klug irgendwie abzuwägen denn die folgen
dieser sanktionen wenn sie länger dauern
werden natürlich die deutsche wirtschaft
irgendwie hart treffen weil die
rohstoffpreise steigen und das ein
großes problem gibt die rüssel
rezessionen in die russen helfen der
bundesregierung schon mal nicht aus
diesem dilemma heraus weil sie sagen
heute dass sie auf jeden fall weiter
liefern werden sie werden vertragstreu
weiter sämtliche rohstoffe liefern
darüber hat sich markus söder schon mal
sehr gefreut und darauf aufmerksam
gemacht dass im schlimmsten kalten krieg
die russen immer verlässlich waren und
man solle doch nicht so viel druck auf
sie ausüben es war ein interview aus dem
januar musik fairerweise dazusagen also
das dilemma der bundesregierung ist
schreiben was fordert die spd das
fordert der spd vorsitzende also erstmal
sehr richtig was wir im
koalitionsvertrag schon verabredet haben
nämlich ganz schnell raus zu kommen aus
der abhängigkeit zu fossilen rohstoffen
jetzt wissen wir das geht nicht von
heute auf morgen deswegen ist auch
richtig was olaf scholz gesagt hat bei
auch wieder hier bei aller emotionalität
aber wir werden an den gaslieferungen
stand jetzt festhalten weil es eine
sanktion ist die wir nicht über zwei
drei jahre durchhalten können und in der
tat der soziale frieden ist gefährdet
die wirtschaft hier ist arbeitsplätze
sind gefährdet und wissen sie denn wenn
menschen wie joachim gauck den ich sehr
schätze aber wenn man darüber redet dass
man drehen kann und das sind das sind
alles nicht die punkte wo ich mich frage
hält man das in drei monaten noch
durchhalten das sind vier monaten noch
durch was wir aber gemacht haben in der
bundesregierung ist ja dass wir kurz vor
kriegsbeginn
sehr starkes entlastungs paket auf den
weg gebracht haben milliarden schwer und
natürlich werden wir weiter beobachten
ob wir noch weitere schritte gehen
müssen bevor ich allerdings warne ist
populismus mit nur dass hans der auch
mitten im wahlkampf ist also von
ministerpräsidenten erwartet man lösung
aber nicht panik videos vor tankstellen
das hilft uns an so einer situation
nicht weiter es ist wahnsinnig schwer zu
entscheiden es wird auch kleinkariert
wenn man sagt dass diese sanktionen uns
natürlich etwas kosten
und dennoch ist die frage muss man nicht
eine kosten nutzen abwägung machen es
ist wie in jedem konflikt nur dieser ist
dramatisch es gibt nicht gute lösungen
und schlechte lösungen es ist immer eine
abwägung und es sind immer kompromisse
die auf der einen das ist wie mit den
waffenlieferungen jeder würde gerne noch
viel viel mehr und viel viel modernere
waffen liefern aber jedermann weiß um
die risiken und deswegen nehmen wir
abstand und ja mit den gaslieferungen
füllen wir die kriegskasse putins muss
man das einfach sagen weil so viel
offensiv mehr stand 200 millionen pro
tag so viel mehr hat dieser russische
staat nicht woher einnahmen generieren
kann und dann steht halt das dilemma
innenpolitisch gegenüber dass ich jetzt
nicht zu beurteilen vermag weil das
nicht mein feld ist aber es drückt
sozusagen die ganze problematik aus die
in diesem krieg existiert und in jedem
krieg der mit sanktionen ist es ist
nicht schwarz es ist nicht weiß es sind
viele grauschattierungen uns ist leider
gottes für die politik immer ein problem
sozusagen welche gruppierung
dann trifft sie und damit natürlich auch
also schuld ist ein falsches wort aber
sozusagen was befördert sie und wenn wir
gas weiterhin beziehen füllen wir putins
kriegskasse ja aber möglicherweise sind
die verwerfungen noch viel viel größer
die natur führen könnten dass wir bei
den sanktionen einknicken müssen wir
unsere bevölkerung sie einfach nicht
mehr mit trägt katja kipping frage an
sie was glauben sie wo endet die
solidarität des deutschen autofahrers
bei 2 euro 50 oder bei drei euro
das hängt vielleicht auch ein bisschen
von seinem einkommen ab und wie stark er
auf ein auto angewiesen ist also für die
akute city also für die akute situation
glaube ich ist es wirklich eine verdammt
schwierige abwägung aber es gibt ja
womöglich zwei lehren die wir aus der
jetzigen situation ziehen müssen zum
einen wir brauchen dringend energie
souveränität und die energiewende für
die ich immer gestritten habe auch immer
darauf ausgerichtet dass wir viel
stärker auf dezentralität gehen und eine
verkehrswende heißt ja nicht dass die
leute sich das autofahren nicht mehr
leisten können die darauf angewiesen
sind sonst müsst ihr heißen dass dort wo
es irgendwie geht menschen mobil sein
können halt auch auf andere art und
weisen also deswegen das ist jetzt keine
lösung für die akute situation aber wenn
wir uns unabhängiger machen wollen von
despoten wie putin gibt der weltweit
auch noch ein paar andere
dann würde ich sagen ist energie
souveränität ein ganz entscheidender weg
wie man jetzt mit aller energie schönes
wortspiel mit aller energie in angriff
nehmen muss klaus von dohnanyi auch ein
kurzer gang noch mal nach hamburg würden
sie auch sagen es gibt ab einem
bestimmten punkt sorge um den sozialen
frieden in diesem land oder würden sie
sagen das was jetzt hilft noch mal die
ukraine bitten uns darum das tun sie
jeden tag würden sie sagen das was jetzt
hilft muss sofort getan wenn
also sanktionen erfahrungsgemäß sind
notwendig die sanktionen die gemacht
wurden auch sie haben bisher da kann man
weit zurückgehen und das über schauen
immer sehr wenig gebracht und deswegen
glaube ich schon dass wenn wir das hier
überziehen wir innenpolitische vor
großen problemen stehen könnten die den
preis eigentlich nicht wert weil die
sanktionen werden werden putin nicht
bewegen den krieg zu beenden
ich wiederhole zu beenden und des
krieges müssen wir mit putin verhandeln
über die chancen die eventuell bestehen
im zusammenhang mit der ukraine als teil
der nato als neutrales land oder wir
immer wir müssen verhandeln dass es der
weg und wir werden nach meiner meinung
mit sanktionen putin nicht bewegen den
krieg zu wenden so notwendig die
sanktionen sind wir werden aber den
krieg damit nicht beenden und darum geht
es doch letzten endes entscheiden und
heiligung des krieges an die beendigung
des unglücks der ukraine und der auf
vielen toten um eine million flüchtlinge